can I thank the Prime Minister for
advanced sites of his statement
and can I join with him in the comments
about the tragic loss of life in
solihull which is unimaginably
unbearable for the families the friends
and the whole of the community
Channel Crossings are a serious problem
requiring serious Solutions we need
leadership at home and abroad we need a
home office that functions effectively
and we need to defeat the criminal gangs
operating on the coast
but time and time again this government
has not provided serious Solutions the
Prime Minister sat around the cabinet
table the whole time where there should
have been Solutions we've had unworkable
gimmicks and Mr Speaker as I listened to
that statement
all of that has been said almost word
for word before but last time we had
measures the last time we had
legislation
plenty of newspaper headlines about wave
machines prison ships fantasy Islands
but no effective action
all designed to mask failure to distract
from a broken Asylum system that can't
process claims can't return those with
no right to be here and can't protect
our borders
over 40 000 people across the channel
this year that's a record but only two
percent have had their Asylum claim
process what happens the other 98
they're placed in hotels costing around
seven million pounds a day bad for
refugees who want to rebuild their lives
bad for taxpayers and Mr Speaker this
isn't just a one-off bad year 2022 it's
been bad under the Tories for years last
year the percentage of Channel Crossing
Asylum claims process was just four
percent let those figures sink in
because that's the root of the problem
something has to be done to clear the
backlog I welcome the commitment to Fast
Track clearly unfounded claims that's
what we've been calling for and Britain
is two years behind so many of our
neighbors and allies have been fast
tracking for years
so can the Prime Minister confirm I want
to have an answer on this that he
intends to CL will clear the backlog by
the end of next year and that's 150 000
cases in the backflow well yeah I know
he said it and we'll be back when in a
year but 150 000 cases including the
hundred thousand have been there for
over six months we need clarity about
that I also welcome more staff for
processing it's appalling they let the
backlog get this big nearly a hundred
thousand cases have been waiting more
than six months for a decision that is
the root cause
but processing is only part of the
answer criminal ging criminal gangs are
sending these people to risk their lives
they Thrive because of a total failure
of any coordinated response or any
effective deterrent to their criminal
activity for months we've been calling
for Action to tackle this root cause a
specialist cell in the National Crime
agency a specialist cell in the National
Crime agency to catch prosecute a
disband criminal gangs we need to be
working internationally to end this
cross-border crime again new staff are
welcome but can he guarantee that will
result in prosecutions for those who put
lives and National Security at risk
and Mr Speaker money is being wasted on
the unworkable unethical plan to deport
people to Rwanda
140 million pounds wasted already not a
single deportation and the most senior
civil the most senior civil service in
the home office is the only one in
government to tell the truth
it doesn't even work as a deterrent
exactly the prime ministers promised
more legislation but the last time the
government legislated to tackle the
broken Asylum system they made it work
they made it work
sit Mr Speaker since the nationality of
borders act came into Force Crossings
and delays have increased 18
000 cases have been put through the new
process adding an additional six months
with only 21 returns
slow track not fast track how many
heavily credibility to say new
legislation is going to be the answer
the unworkable gimmicks go on so do the
crossings we need to bring this to an
end that means a proper plan to crack
down on the gangs quick processing
return agreement serious solutions to a
serious problem and that is what labor
will offer
foreign